Donald Trump has now turned on his
darling former press secretary Kaylee
mcinanny in a Bonkers truth social rant
truth Central Donald Trump trothing to
Central quote Kaylee milk toast mcananny
now what oh god
I'm gonna get back to this he writes
milk toast like you would make a piece
of toast with milk like Japanese milk
bread okay
um this is not the word this is not the
spelling of milk toast but we'll get
back to that Kaylee milk toast macanoni
just gave out the wrong poll numbers on
Fox news I am up 30 I am 34 points up on
De sanctimonious not 25 up while 25 is
great it's not 34. she knew the number
was corrected upwards by the group that
did the poll
the rhinos and globalists can have her
Fox News should only use real stars so
let's look at this in pieces first of
all the word is milk toast
m-i-l-q-u-e it has a couple of
definitions timid Meek or unassertive
lacking in character or vigor
um milk toast like we would talk about
bread is something different altogether
although it is delicious I will admit
that Japanese milk bread if you toast it
it is really something else so let's
talk about the strategy the strategy to
the extent that there is one is Trump
turning on everyone
for any reason at all if they don't do
the metaphorical bow down and pray at
the altar of trump
in this particular case Kaylee mcinanny
just gave polling numbers that Trump
feels are different or inaccurate or
were revised in some way it doesn't seem
like this is a good strategy for two
different reasons number one if you are
going to immediately viciously turn on
anyone not even for criticizing you but
just for reporting polling data that may
be disfavorable in some way to you or
not as favorable as you want it to be uh
you are going to very quickly run out of
allies because you're going to end up
turning on a lot of different people and
secondly it runs the risk of alienating
other former staffers even if Trump if
you're a trump former Trump staffer and
I don't know maybe you'd be involved in
his 2024 campaign maybe you wouldn't if
you see Trump turning on other former
staffers for essentially nothing
are you going to be ready and willing to
defend Trump to work for Trump to help
Trump in any way it seems like the
answer is no now this is just this is a
very funny thing
um Kaylee mcinanny was hosting something
on Fox news I guess maybe she has a show
now on Fox News I don't even remember
and Congressman chip Roy uses the word
milk toast as a reference to the fact
that uh Trump called her milk toast this
this is actually a little bit funny
starting with you Congressman chip Roy
what is the realistic alternative to
this because I understand we wouldn't
formally default we can pay the interest
on our debt but our debt could be
downgraded and that could be
catastrophic so what is the realistic
alternative to this deal
well thanks Kaylee uh first of all you
know the everything that we're seeing
out of the bill that was put forward
this this deal this hatch this weekend
is pretty milk toast if uh if that word
might mean something to you but frankly
uh the real problem we've all right so
very very clever there chip Roy
um the more Trump turns on former
staffers the more likely it is that his
2024 campaign will be made up of even
more incompetent staffers which actually
sounds very fun to me even if it's not
going to be a particularly good strategy
for winning in 2024 so Kaylee mcinanny
the latest Trump staffer former staffer
to see Trump turn on them and remember
Trump's idea of loyalty is
you never criticized Trump okay
you never questioned Trump's judgment
all right you always praise Trump
anytime his name comes up it's getting a
little difficult you don't even report
polling data that Trump doesn't like
that's a tough standard for loyalty that
is a genuinely tough standard for
loyalty it's going to be tough to keep
that one up particularly if desantis's
rise in the polls over the last 10 days
is not a blip and it is a new change of
Direction but we will follow it after
the break Joe Biden's sexual assault
accuser Tara Reid has defected to Russia
do you know anything about Russia they
asked me and I said I don't know
anything about it well that's where Joe
Biden's sexual assault accuser has uh
defected to we're going to talk a lot
more about believe all women in the
context of this defection stay tuned